have you had to sum up the rest of the
season with three words what would they
be were those words was it a daunting
thing to come back for your third
go-around a drag race yes because since
I was on RuPaul's Drag Race Season three
and riposte drag race all-stars one many
years have passed and the level of drag
has increased the bars have been risen
and I have a lot of work to do you know
when I was first on the show all those
years ago it was I was trying to prove
myself you know and then I came back on
all-stars one and it was just kind of
like let's show people like what I've
been up to but now it's just like okay
I'm really excited to be back I'm
excited to show like how I've grown as
an artist and yeah but it's hard because
going back onto reality TV have to
remember like okay let's be a reality TV
character sometimes so we gotta like you
know slap a [ __ ] around you know start
some drama women how do you not know
what you're signing up for you dirty did
this girl Oh
Teletubby teleport us to Mars what if
you go back to season three and do
anything over again from that season
what would you do differently
oh I don't know if I could have done
anything differently I mean you made it
pretty far I'm eight I was runner-up on
season three so I did pretty good I mean
I probably could have you know pushed
Raj atomic by the stairs maybe and maybe
won that way but that doesn't seem very
fair or very nice but here's the deal
like I was devastated when I lost from
Paul's drag race season three but I
didn't realize that I wasn't gonna be
able to be on RuPaul's Drag Race a few
more times
so actually I've made my coin back up I
don't need that freaky crown honey I
could buy myself a crowd cheering me I
can get a sash man that says RuPaul's
Drag Race winner
but now I've been I've been able to come
back and the prize money is more and the
audience is bigger so I feel like I got
you know I got a better deal
yeah I'm losing we all have more screen
time than some of the winners yeah
that's very true you know looking ahead
to the rest of the season who were you
clocking as your biggest competition the
one that's like still kind of like makes
me nervous is Naomi because she's just
been like constantly like safe not she's
not in the bottom she's not in the top
she's just flying real like low under
the radar you know giving my eye out for
her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]